oh hey guys what's up I'm Alana and
welcome to my channel today I'm finally
announcing something that I've kind of
trickled across various social media
accounts but haven't officially spoken
about even though I've known about it
since May in May while I was still
living in California I applied for a job
as the toys and culture editor at IGN in
San Francisco the interview process is
pretty insane I had three separate
interviews one of them was with like 15
people or something and went for several
hours had to do a bunch of sample
writing and answer a bunch of questions
and eventually I got the job but because
I was on a visa they didn't allow me to
work and that means I expired on June
30th i GN were trying to get me a
working visa before I left so I think we
had about three weeks and that didn't
happen so I moved back to Australia and
this entire time that I've been back in
Australia which has been five months now
I have effectively just been waiting on
a visa it's been pretty terrible to be
completely honest because I mean the
visa process even to start with was
about forty hours of paperwork I had to
fill out these forms about every article
that I've ever written and every company
that I've ever worked for and every
article ever written about me and that
was just me googling my own name because
I don't have records of that so it was
just like hours and hours an hour but my
visa is physically in my passport right
now and being mailed to me that visa
lasts for three years and allows me to
live and work in the US for a GN for
those three years though I assumed that
if everything goes well we will just
ruin you at the end of the three years
so to talk more about the actual job I
will be a full-time writer I can in San
Francisco as I said my role is toys and
culture editor that basically means that
I will be the section head for stuff to
do with toys collectibles collector's
editions statues stuff that I really
love I think that I'll be doing all
their unboxing videos as well I'm not
sure about that
yeah and I'm actually really happy to
not have to review video games anymore
after doing it for three years I'm
looking forward to going back and
playing Dragon Age 1 and 2 and finishing
Mass Effect 3 and fully and la and allah
and nia and like all of these old games
that i have laying around some of them
still in that plastic that i just
haven't had time to play because i just
have to chew through new releases all
the time so it's gonna be nice to go
back to playing games as a hobby rather
than as a job I'm actually very excited
about that probably the weirdest thing
for me is going to be that this is my
second time ever working a nine-to-five
job first time doing it in the games
media so at the moment while I work full
time hours for the company that I work
for I work sometimes like 70 hours a
week I'm technically employed as a
contractor so I don't work 9:00 to 5:00
and the dot has meant that I obsessively
work a good example of this is that I
follow like a bunch of make up accounts
on Instagram and I really like doing
makeup because I'm a naughty person it's
something that I really enjoy and I
follow all these accounts and sometimes
I'm like you know maybe I could put
effort into doing my makeup every day
and look like these beautiful painted
faces that these girls have put that in
the back of my head and like well why
would I do that when I could be working
that's not productive you could be
writing about something at five o'clock
I leave I Jen I have to stop working
like what am I going to do what do
people do at that time when they can't
work you know what I'm gonna watch some
TV and go for a nice walk I really have
no idea what people do with this bad
time I can't even make a joke about it
what do people do I don't know so that's
what's up with me probably the most
dramatic change of my life that has ever
happened so far I had this opportunity
with Disney in Sydney and kinda had a
choice to make
between the two of them and was like you
know what why don't I go for the one
that completely messes all my [ __ ] up
like you know I'm really comfortable
with my life at the moment I am on good
money and I basically have a lot of
control over all the outlets that I work
for and I like I'm just really
comfortable and I don't think that
Disney would have changed that whereas I
Jan is completely different it's like
working with a team I have an editor
who's above me it's 9:00 to 5:00
completely from country like is she
gonna completely change everything that
I have in my life right now
and I think the way do you grow and
improve as a person is by making
yourself really uncomfortable I'm
basically just [ __ ] off all of the
comforts and I guess I'm almost excited
to see how I will react to that as a
human I'm also just a really weird mix
between incredibly like cripplingly sad
to have to leave my family and I have to
leave my dog behind but then on the
other hand I'm like insanely excited
about the job I'm a team I really like
everyone that I've met who works at IGN
in SF so it's like this weird mix of
things to try and manage it's the
strangest thing it's like a half want to
cry and a half just want to smile
constantly and my head is this complete
mess
I'm very least I'm happy to not be
waiting on a visa anymore and you know I
know what's happening and it's finally
happening
leaving us early on the 24th and
starting on the 30th so it's all getting
done but that is it for me today you
guys thank you for watching and I will
see you next time bye bye